GETS SO FRUSTRATING THAT I CAN'T
CONTINUE.
CHRISTY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: BRIT HUME JOINS US.
YOU'VE BEEN IN THE MEDIA A LONG
TIME AND THE TELEVISION FOR MANY
DAYS.
WHEN YOU SAW SAM NUNBERG, DID
YOU THINK TO YOURSELF, I WOULD
HAVE PUT HIM ON IF I WERE A
>> I VERY MUCH HOPED I WOULD NOT
HAVE.
IT WAS VERY MUCH NOTING, CNN'S
ERIN BURNETT AND SAID I SMELL
LIQUOR ON YOUR BREATH.
COULD SHE HAVE BEEN THE FIRST
AND ONLY CNN ANCHOR TO KNOW THAT
THE GUY WAS DRUNK?
NOT ONLY THAT, HE'S A VERY
TROUBLED SOUL.
AS A JOURNALIST WHEN YOU COME
ALONG, YOU DON'T HAVE TO MAKE A
PSYCHIATRIC DIAGNOSE TO KNOW
THAT SOMEONE YOU'RE TALKING TO
MAY NOT BE OKAY.
WHATEVER THIS PERSON SAYS MAY BE
QUESTIONABLE.
YET THIS GUY HELD SWAY OVER THE
AIRWAVES FOR HOURS ON END,
PARTICULARLY ON CNN.
I GUESS OTHERS PICKED IT UP AND
IT GOT QUITE A RIDE.
THE PRINCIPLE THING THAT MADE
THE HEADLINE IS WHEN HE SAID HE
WASN'T GOING TO COOPERATE WITH
MUELLER.
BY THIS MORNING THAT WAS GONE
AND HE SAID HE WAS GOING TO
COOPERATE WITH MUELLER.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, HE HAS
LITTLE CHOICE.
BUT THAT WAS A NONSTORY THAT
LIVED ALL DAY LONG BECAUSE IT
FEEDS THIS WHOLE NARRATIVE THAT
SOMETHING TERRIBLE IS WRONG AND
WE HAVE AN UNQUALIFIED PRESIDENT
UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF RUSSIA
AND GOD KNOWS WHAT ELSE.
>> Tucker: SO TO MAKE THAT
POINT, YOU HAVE SOMEONE UNDER
THE INFLUENCE OF ALCOHOL AND
JUMP AROUND AND DEGRADE THE
PERSON THAT IS INTERVIEWING HIM.
I WONDER IF THERE'S A COST
LONG-TERM WHEN YOU DO STUFF LIKE
THAT.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, TUCKER, WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT HERE, THERE'S
BEEN A BELIEF FOR THE LONGEST
TEAM THAT THE TRUMP ELECTION WAS
ILLEGITIMATE.
THERE'S A SENSE IN THE MEDIA HIS
ELECTION CONSTITUTES A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY BECAUSE HE'S AN
UNQUALIFIED CHARACTER AND SO
LIKELY TO LEAD US OFF A CLIFF
THAT IT'S A JOB OF THE MEDIA TO
JOIN THE RESISTANCE AND TO FIND
OUT WHAT MUST BE BEHIND HIS
ELECTION AND WHAT SCANDALS MUST
LURK THERE TO TAKE HIM DOWN.
THAT'S PLAINLY WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
THE MEDIA JOINED THE RESISTANCE.
THE COVERAGE OF THIS I THINK HAS
BEEN IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
EXTREMELY ONE-SIDED, MISGUIDED.
ANY NUMBER OF STORIES THAT
TURNED OUT BADLY ALL ALONG THE
WAY.
YOU'LL REMEMBER CNN, THE GROUP
OF THEIR SENIOR PEOPLE SAYING
THAT THEY HAD WORD THAT WHEN
COMEY TESTIFIED THAT HE WAS
TOLD DONALD TRUMP THAT HE WAS
NOT UNDER INVESTIGATION AND THE
NEXT DAY COMEY TESTIFIED THE
OPPOSITE.
YOU WONDER HOW STORIES LIKE THAT
CAN GET PAST THESE SEASONED
JOURNALISTS IF THEY'RE NOT ON A
CRUSADE.
I THINK THEY ARE.
>> Tucker: I REMEMBER WHEN THE
RUSSIANS HACKED THE NATIONAL
POWER GRID.
DO YOU THINK IT MIGHT HELP OH
BUT THEY DIDN'T, OF COURSE.
YOU THINK IT MIGHT HELP THE REST
OF US WATCHING US WHAT YOU
SEEING IS POLITICAL ADVOCACY?
WHAT YOU'RE WATCHING IS ONE SIDE
WAGING PARTISAN BATTLE AGAINST
THE OTHER?
>> YEAH.
BUT YOU KNOW, IT'S STRIKINGLY
EFFECTIVE.
YOUR PREVIOUS GUEST, SHE DIDN'T
WANT TO LET GO OF THE NARRATIVE
THAT IS OUT THERE THAT RUSSIA
HAD AN IMPORTANT EFFECT ON THE
ELECTION.
THE EVIDENCE AS YOU POINTED OUT
IS EXTREMELY LIGHT AT BEST.
YOU KNOW, ANYTHING THAT RUSSIA
DID TO THE TUNE OF A MILLION
DOLLARS A MONTH IS DWARFED BY
THE REST OF THE SPENDING AND THE
OTHER THINGS THAT INFLUENCED THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTIONS.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS HELD ON
TO FOR DEAR LIFE.
IT'S THE STORY OF COVERAGE.
IT'S ENRAGED THAT PEOPLE THAT
SEE THINGS MORE CLEARLY THAN
THAT BUT ON AND ON IT GOES.
YOU SEE IT IN THE CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION OF DEVIN NUNES WHO
PUTS UP WITH UNBELIEVABLE
ASSAULTS ON HIM.
THEY CONTINUE TO THIS DAY THAT
HE'S THE GUY AT FAULT WHERE ON
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE, THERE'S AN
UNBELIEVABLE LEAK FEST.
NOT A PROUD MOMENT RIGHT NOW.
>> AND MSNBC CALLED NUNES A
RUSSIAN AGENT.
TWO YEARS AGO, YOU'D BE FIRED
FOR SAYING SOMETHING LIKE THAT
IF YOU CONTINUE SUPPORT IT.
>> IT'S REPORTERS ON HYSTERIA.
IT'S OVER THE TOP.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A TRUMP
ADMIRERS TO REALIZE THAT THINGS
THAT ARE BEING SAID ARE WILDLY